-Donald Trump has always been
a shameless liar,
but he's taken it
to a new level this week
with his administration's
defenses
of his cruel
family separation policy.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump's only political skill
is his total and complete
lack of shame.
His malignant narcissism allows
him to confidently
and brazenly lie
in a way that most other
politicians
would be too embarrassed
to even try,
like earlier this week
when he claimed
he had cut more regulations
than any previous president
in history,
including fictional ones.
-We've set the all-time record
in history of this country
in cutting regulation.
We've cut more regulations
than any administration,
whether it's 4 years, 8 years,
or 16 years in one case.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
In no cases.
Unless he's talking
about himself,
because it definitely feels
like he's been president
for 16 years.
Trump might -- Trump might
be thinking of FDR,
who was elected
to a fourth term,
but he only served 12 years.
Of course, to know that,
you'd have to be
some kind of history buff
or, you know, in 7th grade.
[ Laughter ]
This is what Trump does.
He just confidently tells
a very specific lie,
and knowing that it's obvious
he's lying.
[ As Trump ] In one case,
there was a president
who served 16 years.
This was, of course, 1492
when Columbus sailed
all the way to India
with his best friend,
Albert Einstein.
And let me -- They had so much
fun on that boat, so m--
That's where they came up
with E equals MC Hammer.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] And then --
[ Applause ]
Then there was Trump's
announcement on Monday
that he had directed
the Pentagon to create
a sixth branch of the military
focused on space.
Trump doesn't actually know
anything about space
or space policy,
so he can't actually explain
why he thinks
a pointless and expensive
space force is necessary.
Instead, he just says
stuff like this.
-You will go out there and you
will take that frontier,
which is largely unknown
by man or woman,
and you will learn everything
there is to know about it.
And what you're doing
is so important.
Remember, economically,
militarily, scientifically,
in every way,
there is no place like space.
[ Laughter ]
-He sounds like an actor
playing Captain Kirk
in a dinner theater production
of "Star Trek"
who forgot all his lines.
He's even got Vanilla Spock
right next to him.
[ Laughter ]
And not only --
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ As Trump ] You know.
[ Normal voice ]
And not only does Trump
confidently and brazenly lie,
but he also insists
that the people who believe
and repeat his lies
are the smart ones,
as he did during his
interview last week
with state TV outlet,
"Fox & Friends."
-I have the greatest supporters
in the world.
By the way,
they're the smartest.
We have the great brain power
right in this country,
I'm proud to say,
and you're certainly a member
of that group.
-No.
Seriously, you think Steve Doocy
has brain power,
the guy who lost [bleep]
when you complimented him
on-air?
-"Fox & Friends" in the morning.
They're very honorable
people.
-Wow!
What do you think about that?
[ Laughter ]
-He sounds like --
[ Applause ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
He sounds like the mushrooms
just kicked in.
"Wow!
A purple demon just told me
how I die.
What do you think of that?"
[ Laughter ]
Trump also loves to insist
in the face
of indisputable evidence
to the contrary
that his lies
are always proven right.
Yesterday, for example,
in defending
his immigration policies,
Trump revisited the foundational
lie of his campaign
that Mexico is not sending
their finest,
insisting that he was
100 percent right.
Obviously, he wasn't,
but this lie is central
to Trump's world view,
and it's a through line we've
seen throughout his presidency,
up to and including his policy
of family separation.
Trump wants to link
immigrants to crime,
even if he has to make stuff up
to do it.
For example, Germany has had
an influx of refugees,
and yet crime is at its lowest
rate since 1992.
But Trump wants you to believe
that immigration leads
to more crime,
so he says stuff like this.
-Germany.
We talk about Germany.
They allowed
millions of people in.
And, by the way, their crime
from the time they started
is up more than 10 percent,
and one of the reasons
it's at that level,
is because they don't like
reporting that kind of crime,
so they put it down
as different kind of crime.
But their crime is up
more than 10 percent
since they've started taking
immi--
-Hey, man, you can't just
make up statistics like that.
That's like me saying,
did you know that 10 percent
of people who work
in the Trump administration
are Draculas?
Which is clearly a lie because
it's at least 30 percent.
[ Laughter ]
And Trump's shamelessness --
[ Applause ]
His shameless lying
is not unique to him.
We saw that
with his cruel policy
of tearing children away from
their parents at the border.
In defending the policy
this week, Kirstjen Nielsen,
Trump's Homeland Security
secretary, tweeted...
Now, one way you know
someone's full of [bleep]
is when they have to say
the punctuation
at the end of their sentence
like this guy did.
-This was the largest audience
to ever witness an inauguration,
period!
-And I am not screaming,
exclamation point!
And when --
when they were insisting
the policy didn't exist,
they were insisting Congress --
Congress -- had to fix it.
-Congress and the courts
created this problem,
and Congress alone can fix it.
-The Democrats
have to change their law.
That's their law.
-It's Congress' job
to change the law.
We're calling on them
to do exactly that.
-Okay. There you go.
Congress alone can fix it,
and Trump can't do it
by himself.
I understand.
-President Trump
abruptly reversing course today,
signing an executive order
to end the separation
of families on the border.
-We're signing
an executive order.
We're keeping families together,
and this will solve
that problem.
-Let's be clear about one thing.
You don't get credit
for solving a problem
when you're the one who created
the problem.
You can't eat --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You can't eat half
a cheeseburger, put it down,
and say you're a vegan,
especially when everyone knows
you're just waiting for people
to stop paying attention
so you can finish
your cheeseburger.
Now, whether
it's the birther lie
or the Mexicans are rapists lie
or the idea that Democrats
are responsible
for separating families,
Trump's paranoid fantasies
are a Rosetta stone
for understanding
what's happening right now.
Just look at Fox News,
which has spent the past week
lying about the policy
and trying to make you believe
that what you're seeing
with your own eyes
isn't actually real.
-Since more illegal immigrants
are rushing the border,
more kids are being separated
from their parents
and temporarily housed
in what are essentially
summer cramp -- camps.
-These kids are being coached.
-I'm so sorry, we have to go.
-They're given scripts to read
by liberals,
according to the New Yorker.
Don't fall
for the actor children.
-We got from the border patrol
some of the images inside
these detention facilities.
Some refer to these as cages,
and I can understand
that point of view.
Look, I'm from a farm community.
To me,
I see the chain link fences.
It's more like a security pen
to me.
-Oh, a security pen.
That's way better.
Look.
Let's be clear about something.
If you rip a child
away from its parents
and you put that child
in a suite at the Ritz,
you're still a [bleep] monster.
When someone's that stupid --
[ Cheers and applause ]
When someone's that stupid,
there is really only one thing
you can say to them.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Also I should note,
that New Yorker article
you heard Ann Coulter cite
to support her insane claim
that child actors are using
scripts at the border
contains no such claim.
In fact, the author of
that piece said of Coulter...
[ Laughter ]
Oh, that's ridiculous.
Of course Ann Coulter
knows how to read.
She communicates
with her Dark Lord every night
by reading a Ouija board.
[ Laughter ]
The through line
of Trump's political career
is blindingly clear.
He concocts racist lies,
uses dehumanizing language
to justify cruelty towards
immigrants and outsiders.
It wasn't an accident,
it wasn't a law,
it was a choice by Trump
and his supporters.
And lest you have
any doubt at all
about how the people who support
this policy really feel,
here's Corey Lewandowski,
Trump's former campaign manager,
on Fox News last night.
-I read today about a
10-year-old girl
with down syndrome who was taken
from her mother
and put in a cage.
-Wah wah.
-I read about a --
Did you just say "wah wah" to
a 10 year old with down syndrome
being taken from her mother?
-What I said is you can pick
anything you want.
-How dare you?
-But the bottom
line is very clear --
-How dare you?
-Man, I thought when
you showed a dick on TV,
you had to blur it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know...
something you hear a lot
on days like today
or days like yesterday is,
"This is not who we are."
But it is who we are right now.
It might change tomorrow
or the day after that,
but today, we are this.
And you personally may not
be this,
but who we are is too often
decided by those in power,
which is why you vote.
So remember,
if you want who we are
to match with who you are,
you have to get up early
and vote next chance you have.
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪